la manifestación de este día sábado es
especialmente importante para los
sindicatos tienen que demostrar que
después de la marcha del día martes que
tuvo menos participación son capaces
todavía de movilizar a la población
francesa en contra de este proyecto de
reforma del gobierno de Manuel macron y
sobre todo provocar una respuesta de
parte del ejecutivo que Hasta ahora ha
hecho oídos sordos a las demandas de la
calle por lo mismo se ha puesto esta
marcha hoy en un día sábado para que
aquellos trabajadores que quizás no
habían marchado por problemas económicos
Para no perder un día de trabajo
pudieran venir y también pudieran venir
aquellos trabajadores del sector
privados para quienes es muy difícil
manifestar un día entre semana nosotros
conversamos con alguna de esas personas
que hoy marchan aquí en París y bueno a
los 64 años quiere decir que la gente
porque hay que tener 40 y tantos años de
cotizaciones quiere decir que uno
empieza muy temprano a trabajar para
irse a los 64 años pero si usted tiene
ese estudio y no ha podido encontrar
trabajo va a tener trabajar hasta los 65
66 años entonces es por eso importante
porque un proyecto de sociedad sobre
todo y que este gobierno que no es solo
por la jubilación sino porque hay un
malestar general muy importante falta de
medios para vivir la jubilaciones son
muy pobres hay un estado general de
tristeza de
de fatiga no sé cómo decirles entonces
las luchas son válidas por ahora la
manifestación aquí en la capital
francesa está haciendo todo un éxito
hemos visto a mucha gente ha habido
algunos incidentes como quema de objetos
o ruptura de cristales sin embargo en su
mayoría se ha realizado de manera
pacífica hemos visto familias con niños
personas activas pero también no
jubilados que están aquí Para apoyar a
las nuevas generaciones para que no
pierdan esas garantías que tanto ha
costado conquistar Los sindicatos
prefieren todavía seguir con este tipo
de manifestaciones meterán la presión
después de marzo Una vez que se vuelva
de vacaciones de invierno pues no
quieren llevarse en contra a la gente a
los ciudadanos franceses que por ahora
apoyan este movimiento más de un 60 por
ciento